From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt sitting in for Ira Glass this week. In today's show, we've got stories of people at a moment of understanding something they could not have grasped before when they were younger-- stories from childhood, 10 years old, all the way up through old age, 79.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，本周代班Ira Glass。在今天的节目中，我们讲述了一些人对某些事物产生理解的瞬间，这是他们年轻时无法领悟的——故事涵盖了从10岁孩童到79岁老人的各个年龄段。
So let's start at the beginning. I should say that the entire premise of this show, the idea that there are certain things that do not make sense when you're young, it is flat out offensive to the people at the beginning of our story.
那么让我们从头说起。我得说，本节目的整个前提，即认为有些事情在年轻时无法理解，这在我们的故事开头的那群人看来，简直是彻头彻尾的冒犯。
Have you guys ever heard the phrase, you'll understand this when you're older? Or this will make sense--
你们有没有听过这句话：等你长大了就明白了？或者说，这以后就懂了——
Oh, my gosh.
天哪。
Yes. A bunch of times.
是的，听过很多次。
I'm sitting with a half dozen sixth graders at a table in their middle school. And a small guy with glasses and a comic book name Bernard Arthur keeps shaking his head.
我正和六名六年级的学生坐在中学里的一张桌子旁。一个小个子戴眼镜、有着漫画角色般名字的男生Bernard Arthur一直在摇头。
I'm at the point where I'm used to it now, you know? Because they say it lots of times. And it's not only from my mom. It's from her friends, from adults, and from everybody. So I'm just really sick of it.
我已经习惯了，你知道吗？因为他们说了无数次了。这不仅是我妈说的，她的朋友、大人们、每个人都这么说。所以我真的受够了。
To be honest, to be completely honest--
老实说，说实话——
Be completely honest.
说实话。
I know-- we all know mostly everything about life.
我知道——我们对生活中的绝大多数事情都心知肚明。
Wait, so you don't believe that phrase at all?
等等，所以你根本不相信那句话？
It's not like we know everything, but we know mostly what adults think we don't know.
并不是说我们什么都知道，但大人认为我们不懂的那些东西，其实我们大部分都懂。
Bernard just feels like that stuff you think I'm not ready for? I am. Let's talk.
Bernard只是觉得，那些你认为我还不够成熟去面对的事情？其实我准备好了。我们来谈谈吧。
At least three kids at the table raise a finger and politely say, "um, I'd like to add to that." They've all got examples of questions they asked recently that were met with some version of, you'll understand later. A brief selection, why do you smoke? Why did she commit suicide? Why do I have to go to school?
桌上至少有三个孩子举起手指，礼貌地说：“呃，我想补充一点。”他们都有近期提问却被类似“你以后就会明白”的话搪塞的经历。简短列举一下：你为什么要抽烟？她为什么要自杀？我为什么非得上学？
What does it mean to hit puberty? Who is puberty? And why would you hit her?
“经历青春期”是什么意思？青春期是谁？你为什么要打她？
How do you say butt hole in Spanish? It's a pretty broad range, right?
用西班牙语怎么说“屁眼”？这范围还挺广的，对吧？
A girl named Samantha Boome says sometimes you don't even have to ask a question to be shut down with the "you'll understand later," even if it's not those exact words. Like the other night, she came into the kitchen. And her mom and grandpa were talking in loud voices, maybe they were fighting.
一个叫Samantha Boome的女孩说，有时你甚至不需要提问，对方就会用“你以后就明白了”来堵你的嘴，即使不是这几个字。比如那天晚上，她走进厨房。她妈妈和外公正在大声说话，可能是在吵架。
And I was like, "hey, can I get the cookie jar to get some cookies?" And they're like, "no. You can't. You'll learn when you get older."
我当时说：“嘿，我可以拿饼干罐吃点饼干吗？”他们却说：“不行。你不能拿。等你长大了就知道了。”
She's saying, you'll learn when you get older.
她说是“等你长大了就知道了”。
I'm like, but I was just asking for a cookie. She's like, "I'm not in the mood right now. I'm talking to your grandfather." I'm like, "oh, my god. But, Mom, chill out." And then I had to walk out of the room. I'm like, sheesh. Now I can't get a cookie.
我就想，我不过是想吃块饼干。她说：“我现在没心情。我正在和你外公说话。”我心想：“天哪。妈妈，冷静点。”然后我只好走出房间。我心想，天哪。现在连饼干也吃不成了。
I think to kids, this phrase can feel both dismissive and like we, the adults, are abdicating our responsibility, giving up on even trying. Like Jasper Pena says, when he asks what seems like a pretty simple question, sometimes grown-ups say--
我想对于孩子来说，这句话既让人感到被轻视，又觉得我们这些大人在逃避责任，放弃了尝试。就像Jasper Pena说的，当他问出一个看似很简单的问题时，大人们有时会说——
Probably only God knows the answer. I don't know the answer, but I know that God knows it. And I get frustrated when they say that.
可能只有上帝知道答案。我不知道答案，但我知道上帝知道。他们那样说的时候，我感到很沮丧。
Why?
为什么？
Because you're like, I know that they know the answers. And something's telling me they know the answers.
因为你会觉得，我知道他们是知道答案的。冥冥之中有个声音告诉我，他们知道答案。
You can't have a conv-- you can, but you can't like physically have a conversation with him and ask him the question. That's like--
你无法与上帝进--你可以，但你不能真切地与他对话并问他问题。那是——
With God?
与上帝？
Yeah. It's better if you ask an actual person because they will actually give you an answer because they know the people, instead of God.
对。最好还是去问真实的人，因为他们会真正给你一个答案，因为他们了解当事人，而不是上帝。
She wants an actual person. These kids want answers. Well, today on our show, we have answers. Or rather, we have people arriving at the answers themselves, with or without the help of others. People looking ahead in time for clues of what's to come, and looking back at the remarkable facts that they somehow missed. We're going to travel from childhood on up, stopping at all the points where people do understand, finally. We've got Sasheer Zamata from Saturday Night Live . Stay with us.
她想要一个真实的人。这些孩子想要答案。嗯，在今天的节目中，我们有答案。或者更确切地说，我们有人们自己找到答案的故事，无论有没有他人的帮助。人们展望未来寻找未来的线索，回顾过去发现那些他们以某种方式错过的惊人事实。我们将从童年开始，一路前行，停留在人们终于理解的每一个节点。我们请到了《周六夜现场》的Sasheer Zamata。请继续收听。
Act One, Adolescence. When the biggest thing that does not make sense is often just the immediate future and how you're going to get through it. Here's Hillary Frank.
第一幕，青春期。当最让人想不通的事情通常只是近在眼前的未来，以及你将如何熬过去时。这是Hillary Frank的报道。
There's this kid in my town. We'll call him Ben. A few years ago, Ben was starting high school, and he turned 15. He asked his parents if he could throw a party. They said yes, but if we see any alcohol, we're shutting it down. Ben's like, fine.
我所在的镇上有个孩子，我们就叫他Ben吧。几年前，Ben刚上高中，满了15岁。他问父母能不能办个派对。父母答应了，但条件是如果看到任何酒精，立刻叫停。Ben说，没问题。
The day of the party he takes a walk with his five closest guy friends. They're sort of his planning committee. They tell him they're going to text invites to, like, 30 people. Mostly, they're other geeky guy friends. Also, their friends tell him, we're going to invite some popular girls.
派对当天，他和他最亲密的五个男生朋友一起散步。他们算是策划委员会。他们告诉他，要发短信邀请大约30个人。大多是些书呆子朋友。而且，朋友们还告诉他，我们要邀请一些受欢迎的女孩。
They were basically like, you'll be the man for a week if you do this.
他们大体上是说，只要这么做，你这周就是这里的老大了。
They all go back to Ben's house. And the popular girls, they're actually the first to show up.
他们都回到了Ben家。那些受欢迎的女孩实际上是最先到的。
And then half an hour in, I make the biggest mistake of my life up to this point when one of the girls, one of the "popular," quote, unquote, girls asked me what my address was. And in my mind-- in my freshman mind-- they were getting picked up. They were already getting picked up, like they were telling their parents to come get them. Because that's what asking for an address meant to me at this time, like, completely innocent thing.
半小时后，我犯了迄今为止人生中最大的错误。当时其中一个女孩，那个所谓的“受欢迎”女孩问我的地址。在我的大脑里——在我高一的大脑里——她们是在叫车。她们已经在叫车了，就像是在让父母来接她们一样。因为在当时的我看来，询问地址就是这个意思，完全是一件无辜的事情。
Four or five more girls asked for Ben's address. Of course, these kids are not calling their rides. They're texting his address to all their friends.
又有四五个女孩要了Ben的地址。当然，这些孩子根本没在叫车。她们是在给所有的朋友发短信告知他的地址。
So the party slowly starts growing. And then a bunch of older kids show up. Then Ben hears banging outside on his garage door. Suddenly, there's a bunch of upperclassman everywhere.
于是派对的人数慢慢开始增加。接着一堆高年级学生出现了。然后Ben听到车库门外传来砰砰声。突然间，到处都是高年级学生。
They were coming up from behind, in the flanks, and the front. And people were looking in the bushes and crawling to all the different windows, looking in, seeing who's in there. I'd say about half of them are people I know. But it's the people I know that I would never want them to come. And it's kids that bullied me in middle school and elementary school. And they're calling people inside trying to get in through the back.
他们从后面、侧翼、前面围了上来。人们在灌木丛里窥探，爬向不同的窗户往里看，看看里面有谁。我敢说其中大约有一半是我认识的人。但恰恰是我那些最不想让他们来的人。他们是初中和小学时欺负过我的孩子。他们正在召集里面的人，试图从后门进入。
This thing that was happening to Ben, it's straight out of every memorable teen party movie. His little birthday celebration was crashed. But what was happening here is different from those movies in one key way, a way that seems to be specific to my town and towns nearby.
Ben身上发生的这件事，简直就是每一部令人难忘的青少年派对电影里的情节。他的小型生日庆典被搞砸了。但这里发生的事情与电影有一个关键的不同点，这是一个似乎只发生在我镇上及附近小镇的特有现象。
Upperclassman conspire to target freshman parties, freshman like Ben. And at these parties, the parents are home. The older kids, though, they are not deterred by parents. Parents can be yelling at them to get off their lawn, and the kids will pretend to go, but really they are sneaking in around back. And once they get in, they tell the younger kids, this is our party now.
高年级学生串通一气，专门针对高一新生的派对，比如Ben这样的。而且在这些派对上，父母都在家。但高年级学生并不被父母所阻碍。父母可能在冲他们大吼让他们离开草坪，孩子们会假装离开，但实际上他们正溜到后门。一旦进去，他们就会告诉低年级孩子：现在这是我们的派对了。
This is so common in my town that parents are calling it parasiting. They try to deal with it themselves. They try not to call the cops. They don't want their kids to be humiliated, but it can get overwhelming.
这在我镇上太普遍了，以至于父母们称之为“寄生”。他们试图自己处理。他们尽量不报警。他们不想让自己的孩子蒙羞，但这确实会让人难以应付。
One mom I talked to got a call from a friend while this was going on at her house. The friend warned her, they'll find a way around you. You can't stop them.
我采访过的一位母亲在自家发生这种事时接到了朋友的电话。朋友警告她：他们总能绕过你。你阻止不了他们的。
It's like a military raid. It's like D-Day. It's like any sort of multifaceted attack where the base is just completely up for grabs and anything goes. And all morals are just thrown out the window completely.
这就像是一次军事突袭。就像诺曼底登陆。这就像任何一种多方位的攻击，基地完全处于被占领状态，什么事都可能发生。所有的道德准则都被抛到了九霄云外。
The party has more than doubled in size. There are now 70 kids at Ben's house. His mom's on the lawn, calling out kids by name and threatening to tell their parents that they were here. His dad is getting into it with some kid who's trying to push his way inside the house.
派对规模增加了一倍多。Ben家现在有70个孩子。他妈妈在草坪上大声喊出那些孩子的名字，威胁说要告诉他们的家长他们来过这儿。他爸爸正和一个试图强行闯入屋里的孩子发生冲突。
Ben looks around. He's surrounded by strangers-- older strangers. They're chugging beer. They're on their phones explaining to their friends the best method of breaking into the house. Ben's standing right next to them as they're doing this. Someone turns up the music, and a corner of the basement suddenly becomes a dance floor. The toilet is full of beer cans.
Ben环顾四周。他被陌生人包围了——年长的陌生人。他们在大口喝酒。他们拿着手机向朋友解释闯入房子的最佳方法。Ben就站在他们旁边，听着他们这样做。有人调大了音乐，地下室的一个角落突然变成了舞池。厕所里全是啤酒罐。
There is this girl who's chugging something. I don't remember. I told her, "can you please not do this?" And she looked at me and in the most rude, sarcastic voice said to me, "like, thanks for the hospitality," and turned around and just trudged back in a different direction.
有个女孩在大口喝着什么，我不记得了。我告诉她：“你可以别这样吗？”她看着我，用一种极其粗鲁、讽刺的语调对我说：“呵，多谢款待啊。”然后转过身，拖着步子朝另一个方向走开了。
After about an hour, kids started calling their friends telling them to not bother coming in. This party was lame. And as quickly as they came, they left.
大约一小时后，孩子们开始打电话给朋友，告诉他们别费心过来了。这个派对没劲透了。他们来得快，去得也快。
I was freaking out the entire time. I'm still freaking out about it just thinking about it. It was horrible. It was pretty scarring.
我当时全程都在抓狂。即使现在一想到这件事，我还是感到心慌。太可怕了。这相当令人受创。
For the rest of Ben's freshman year, he was terrified of older kids. He'd go to parties, but he hated when they'd get blown up. He hated when the older kids would take their control away.
在Ben剩下的高一一年里，他一直很怕高年级学生。他还会去派对，但他讨厌派对被搞砸。他讨厌高年级学生夺走控制权。
But Ben grew up. He's a senior now. And he says--
但Ben长大了。他现在是高四学生了。他说——
Somewhere between sophomore and junior year, I just decided I was completely comfortable with showing up with my friends to random people's houses and treating them with the same lack of respect that I was treated with when I was in ninth grade because that's what you do.
在高二和高三之间的某个时候，我决定完全可以和朋友们一起出现在陌生人的家里，并以当年我高一时被对待的那种缺乏尊重的方式对待他们，因为这就是规矩。
He started getting those texts saying there's a party happening at so-and-so's and house. Let's blow it up. He started getting invited more and more till eventually the text would just be an address, nothing else. But he'd know what it meant.
他开始收到那些短信，说某某人家里有派对。去搞砸它吧。他开始收到越来越多的邀请，直到最后短信里只剩下一个地址，没有别的。但他知道这意味着什么。
[YELLING]
[尖叫声]
This sound comes from a video that Ben sent me that one of his friends shot at a party.
这个声音来自Ben发给我的一段视频，是他一个朋友在派对上拍的。
All the (PRETENDING TO YELL) "yo's" and "look at that"-- it's all just like you're kind of in awe where you've ended up in that moment. "That's that kid from my biology class. Like, oh, my god. Come over here."
所有的“哟”和“快看那个”——你只是在那个瞬间对你的境遇感到敬畏。看，“那是生物课上的那个孩子。天哪。快过来。”
That's one of the things Ben told me he loves about crashing freshman parties. You never know who's going to show up. It's like nobody's invited, so everybody's invited.
这是Ben告诉我他喜欢搞砸高一派对的原因之一。你永远不知道谁会出现。这就好比没有人被邀请，所以每个人都被邀请了。
Also, it's super convenient. There's always a party because you don't have to wait for your friend's parents to go out of town. And Ben says it's thrilling, what it takes to get into the house -- the Black Ops -- getting intel from your friends inside about which entryways are guarded and which are clear.
而且，这非常方便。总会有派对，因为你不必非得等朋友的父母出远门。Ben说这很刺激，进入房子需要做些什么——就像特种作战——从里面的朋友那里获取情报，知道哪些入口有守卫，哪些是畅通的。
But yes, it is like a stealth mission a lot of the times, seeking out which route is the most efficient form of entry. Next time, maybe I'll bring a notepad and sketch out my ideas or draw a blueprint of the house because that's basically what we're doing.
但是是的，这很多时候就像一次潜行任务，寻找哪条路线是最高效的入口。下次，也许我会带个记事本，草拟一下想法或者画一张房子的蓝图，因为这基本就是我们在做的事情。
And it feels OK to you, even though that happened to you when you were a freshman?
即使你自己高一时经历过这些，你依然觉得这样做没问题吗？
Well, let me put it this way. And this is kind of not the best mentality. But if I don't show up, nothing is going to change. So I'm going to show up like everyone else because me not going isn't going to stop anything from happening.
好吧，我换个说法。这心态可能不太好。但如果我不去，什么都不会改变。所以我还是会像其他人一样去，因为我不去并不能阻止任何事情发生。
Well, in reality, I never pictured myself as one of those kids. We would always be like, wow, those kids are such jerks. We'll never be like them. But once you're older, you just-- your mindset turns into, I am one of the older kids. I have power over the younger kids. And that is a new form of intimidation.
嗯，事实上，我从来没想过自己会成为那些孩子中的一员。我们过去总会说，哇，那些孩子真是混蛋。我们永远不会变成那样。但一旦你长大了，你的心态就会变成：我是那些高年级学生中的一员。我对低年级学生有掌控权。这是一种新的恐吓形式。
Ben spent two hours at my house sitting on my couch answering my questions. It all seemed to be getting a little too real for him. He was struggling to make sense of the boy he'd been and the man he'd become. By the end, he was lying down, rubbing his head.
Ben在我家沙发上坐了两个小时，回答我的问题。这一切对他来说似乎变得太真实了。他一直在努力理清曾经的那个男孩和现在的他之间的矛盾。最后，他躺了下来，揉着头。
Wow, I'm really just-- I'm really just conflicting myself everywhere.
哇，我真的……我真的在处处自我冲突。
Ben started philosophizing, talking about all the ways you change so quickly during those years in high school. He told me there are three phases when it comes to blowing up parties. Phase one is when you get blown up. You're an innocent, naive little freshman. Phase two, you're doing the blowing up. And it is deliciously sadistic. Phase three, you're kind of over it.
Ben开始进行哲学思考，谈论你在高中那些年里变化如此之快的所有方式。他告诉我，在搞砸派对这件事上有三个阶段。第一阶段是你的派对被搞砸了。你是一个天真、幼稚的高一新生。第二阶段，你是搞破坏的人。这感觉美味得近乎变态。第三阶段，你觉得有点无聊了。
And I realized that that's just like the circle of life in high school. It's like at a certain point you reach a sort of wise, old sage status because I guess we're getting more mature now. But there is a gap between your immaturity and your maturity where you're still immature but you think you aren't.
我意识到这就像高中生活的循环。就像在某个时刻，你达到了某种睿智的老圣人状态，因为我想我们现在越来越成熟了。但在你的不成熟和成熟之间存在一个鸿沟，你仍然不成熟，但你以为自己不是。
So you take the authority, and you say, I have the right to show up at this person's house because I'm old. And I'm 16 years old. And I'm going to be applying to college soon. And I grew a mustache a few days ago.
所以你夺过权威，说，我有权出现在这个人家里，因为我老了。而且我16岁了。我很快就要申请大学了。我几天前还长了胡子。
What would you say now to your freshman self?
你现在会对高一的自己说什么？
I would say, don't let other people decide who's going to come to your house. Or I would say, don't have a party ever.
我会说，别让别人决定谁可以来你家。或者我会说，永远别办派对。
Ben's got a few months left in his senior year. He's more choosy about parties these days, but he says he'll still go because he's got to do this while he still can. In the fall, he'll start college. And he's pretty sure the parties there will be more sophisticated. And by that, I mean he won't have to break and enter. He'll walk through the front door like a real grown-up.
Ben高四只剩下几个月了。这些天他对派对更挑剔了，但他还是会去，因为他必须趁还能这么做的时候多做点。秋天他就要开始上大学了。他很确定那里的派对会更高级。我指的是，他不需要再非法闯入了。他会像个真正的大人一样从前门走进去。
Hillary Frank is host of the wonderful parenting podcast The Longest Shortest Time . It's on the Earwolf network. longestshortesttime.com.
Hillary Frank是精彩育儿播客《The Longest Shortest Time》的主持人。它在Earwolf网络上。longestshortesttime.com。
Act Two, Grown.
第二幕，成年。
Sasheer Zamata is a comedian. She's on Saturday Night Live . She does a lot of her own stand-up. And like a lot of comics, Sasheer uses the stage to rehash real things that happened to her and try to make sense of them.
Sasheer Zamata是一位喜剧演员。她在《周六夜现场》工作。她做了很多自己的单口喜剧。像许多喜剧演员一样，Sasheer利用舞台来重新梳理她身上发生的真实事情，并试图搞清楚它们。
But recently, Sasheer felt like there was more to figure out about the stuff she was saying on stage. A warning-- the thing that kicked this off for her involves a nasty word, a racial slur. And there is no way for her to tell what happened without saying it a bunch of times. Sasheer's story about this starts with her on stage.
但最近，Sasheer觉得她自己在舞台上说的那些内容还有更多的东西需要去挖掘。警告一下——引发这一切的事情涉及到一个恶毒的词，一个种族歧视的称呼。如果不说这个词好几次，她就无法讲述发生的事情。Sasheer关于这件事的故事始于她在舞台上。
I got called the n-word once in my life, thankfully. And it happened in such a stereotypical way, you won't believe it. I was walking down the street in Cocoa Beach, Florida. Of course, it happened in Florida.
我这一生中曾经被叫过一次“黑鬼”，谢天谢地只有一次。而且它发生得如此刻板，你们都不会相信。我当时走在佛罗里达州可可海滩的一条街上。当然，它发生在佛罗里达。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And I was walking with another friend who's also a black woman. And this dirty pickup truck comes barreling down the road towards us. And it had a Confederate flag vanity plate.
我当时和另一个也是黑人女性的朋友走在一起。然后那辆肮脏的皮卡车朝我们疾驰而来。它有一个邦联旗的装饰车牌。
And this very red-faced man-- that's the politically correct way to say it.
而那个脸涨得通红的男人——这是比较政治正确的说法。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
A very red-faced man leans his face out the window. And he has these reflector sunglasses that strap to your head. And he yells at us. And he goes, "y'all niggas need to take yo' black asses back to Africa." And keeps going.
那个脸涨得通红的男人把脸探出车窗。他戴着那种系在头上的反光太阳镜。他对着我们大叫。他说：“你们这些黑鬼需要把你们的黑屁股滚回非洲去。”然后继续开走了。
And I was like, were we punked? He had all the things.
我当时心想，我们是被恶搞了吗？他拥有所有的特征。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
He had all the racist trappings. Like he did it on purpose. Like he went into a store and was like, "I need to look at as racist as I feel."
他拥有所有的种族歧视标签。就像他是故意的。就像他走进一家店说：“我需要看起来像我内心感受到的那么种族歧视。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I've been telling a joke for a couple of years now. And it always gets a laugh. But when it happened, it was really scary. And it must have really shook me up because I did something I rarely do when I'm upset. I called my mom. And she actually found it funny.
我讲这个笑话已经好几年了。它总是能引起笑声。但当事情发生时，真的很可怕。而且它一定真的让我受到了震动，因为我做了一件我心烦意乱时很少做的事。我给我妈打了电话。结果她觉得很好笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You laughed at me. I was crying. And I called you from the car. And I was like, they called me a nigger. That's never happened to me. And you were like, please.
你当时在嘲笑我。我在哭。我从车里给你打电话。我说，他们叫我“黑鬼”。这种事从来没在我身上发生过。你当时说，得了吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Every day of the eighth grade I was a different flavor of nigger. Nigger all day long. Nigger on the bus. Nigger in the bathroom.
八年级的每一天，我都是各种不同口味的“黑鬼”。整天都是黑鬼。校车上是黑鬼。洗手间里是黑鬼。
From kids?
是被孩子们？
From the kids, yeah.
被孩子们，对。
I was like 20 or 21. That was the first I ever heard that or, like, it's ever been used to me. It's at least nice that--
我当时大概20或21岁。那是我第一次听到那个词，或者说第一次有人这样称呼我。至少值得庆幸的是——
It took that long.
等了那么久。
--it took that long,
——等了那么久，
But, yeah, it still doesn't feel good.
但是，是的，感觉仍然不好。
No, it does not feel good.
不，确实感觉不好。
Up until that point, I hadn't really thought about the fact that my mom got called the n-word all the time when she was younger. But my mom would often drop little tidbits of information like that. And like most kids, I ignored them because she's my mom. And her life before being my mom didn't really concern me. But I did notice some of her patterns when I was a kid.
在那之前，我并没有真正去想我妈妈年轻时经常被叫“黑鬼”这件事。但我妈妈经常会抛出一些像那样的碎片信息。像大多数孩子一样，我忽略了它们，因为她是我妈妈。她在做我妈之前的生活并不怎么让我关心。但我确实在小时候注意到她的一些模式。
There are little things that I remember from my childhood. Like I remember she does not love white people. I mean, I'm sure she'd like you guys if she met you.
我记得童年里有一些小事。比如我记得她不喜欢白人。我是说，我相信如果她遇见你们，她会喜欢你们的。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
You guys are fine. But it would come out in little ways. It wouldn't be crazy overt, but I remember little instances happening when I was younger. Like there was one time we were in the car. She was driving, and I was in the passenger seat.
你们挺好的。但这会以细微的方式表现出来。不会疯狂到明显的地步，但我记得我小时候发生过的一些小插曲。比如有一次我们在车里。她在开车，我坐在副驾驶。
And she stopped to let this old, white couple to pass in front of her. And she lets out this deep sigh like, ehh, white people. And I was like, uhh. They're not even talking to us right now. What's the issue? And she goes, memories. And that's where the conversation stopped.
她停下来让一对年老的白人夫妇从她面前经过。她发出一声沉重的叹息，像“哎，白人”。我就说，呃。他们甚至没跟我们说话。有什么问题？她说，记忆。这就是对话结束的地方。
The conversation stopped there because she never went into those memories. And I also never asked about them. I just assumed that my mom said things like that because she was old-school or close-minded. But I'm getting older. And I'm thinking about race more. I'm talking about it more in my act. And I thought, I should talk to my mom about this stuff. Why does she hate white people?
对话在那儿终止了，因为她从未深谈那些记忆。我也从未问过。我只是单纯地认为我妈说那些话是因为她老派或者思想狭隘。但我正在变老。我正在更多地思考种族问题。我在自己的表演中更多地讨论它。我想，我应该和我妈谈谈这些。她为什么恨白人？
Until a few months ago, I knew very little about what she went through. I knew that in the '60s, my mom became one of the first black students to integrate a white junior high school in Forrest City, Arkansas. It was a big deal. She was part of history. And that's something I figured she'd be proud of.
直到几个月前，我对她经历过的事情知之甚少。我知道在60年代，我妈妈成为第一批整合进入白人初中的黑人学生之一，在阿肯色州的福雷斯特城。那是一件大事。她是历史的一部分。我本以为她会为此感到骄傲。
No, I didn't feel like it was a good thing. We never had a choice in the matter.
不，我不觉得那是什么好事。我们从来没有选择权。
When she says "we," she means her and her siblings. It was her mom who had the choice. I didn't know it was an option for families, that they got to choose whether they'd desegregate schools. I just thought some law was passed, and everyone agreed to go for it. But my grandmother basically forced my mom and several of her siblings to join the civil rights movement as pre-teens and go to a school where they weren't wanted.
当她说“我们”时，是指她和她的兄弟姐妹们。选择权在我外婆手里。我以前不知道家庭还有选择权，可以选择是否要对学校进行种族融合。我以为只是通过了一项法律，每个人都同意照做。但实际上是我外婆强迫我妈妈和她的几个兄弟姐妹在青春期前就加入民权运动，去了一所他们并不受欢迎的学校。
She had said that the reason that she wanted her kids to go to the white school was that she did not want her children to be afraid of white people. But I'm thinking, that's your problem. You're afraid of white people. We didn't get the opportunity to develop how we thought about it.
她说她想让孩子们去白人学校的原因是，她不想让她的孩子害怕白人。但我心想，那是你的问题。是你害怕白人。我们并没有机会去培养我们自己对这件事的看法。
Did you ever talk to your mom about stuff she went through? Do you know what she went through as a black woman in the South growing up?
你有没有和你妈妈谈过她经历过的事情？你知道她作为一个在南方长大的黑人女性经历过什么吗？
She was very close-mouthed. So no, she wouldn't talk about it.
她守口如瓶。所以没有，她不会谈论它。
Did you ever ask?
你问过吗？
Yes. And you get told it ain't your business.
问过。你得到的回答是“这不关你的事”。
It ain't your business?
“这不关你的事”？
It ain't your business. I quote, "it ain't your business."
这不关你的事。我引用原话：“这不关你的事。”
Seems like not talking about this particular subject is a tradition in our family. When I asked my mom why she never talked to me about this, she said she didn't want me to inherit her feelings about white people and she wanted me to come to my own conclusions. But the more questions I asked, especially about school, the more I felt like she didn't want to talk about it because it's still really painful to her.
看来不谈论这个特定的话题是我们家族的传统。当我问我妈为什么从不跟我谈这些时，她说她不想让我继承她对白人的感受，她希望我能得出自己的结论。但我问的问题越多，尤其是关于学校的，我就越觉得她不想谈论它，因为这对她来说仍然非常痛苦。
So then you were just thrust into this all-white environment?
所以当时你就直接被推进了这个全白人的环境？
Yes.
是的。
What was your first day like? Do you remember?
你的第一天是怎么过的？你还记得吗？
We get lots of instructions. Do not argue with them. Do not antagonize them. Hold your tongue.
我们得到了很多指示。不要跟他们争论。不要激怒他们。闭上你的嘴。
There was a lot of cussing at us while we were sitting on the bus. And Mama had told us, sit in the front of the bus so in case something happens, the bus driver is a witness. Well, he was just a witness to us getting cussed out every day. He did nothing.
当我们坐在校车上时，有很多对我们的辱骂。妈妈告诉我们，坐在车的前面，这样万一发生了什么事，校车司机就是一个目击者。嗯，他只是我们每天被辱骂的目击者。他什么也没做。
When we get off the bus, we stood outside the window of the office so if anything happened, then they could witness something happening to us. The person I remember standing in the window was Coach Collier, who later became the principal. So he witnessed the kids throwing rocks at us.
当我们下车时，我们站在办公室的窗外，这样如果发生任何事，他们就能目击到我们遭遇的事情。我记得站在窗边的人是Collier教练，他后来成了校长。所以他目击了孩子们向我们扔石头。
I remember I had on a white blouse, a houndstooth vest, and a black skirt, and had my cute little white bobby socks. And I remember looking down at my legs and how the rocks had pelted them. And one had broke blood.
我记得当时穿着一件白衬衫、千鸟格背心和黑裙子，还有我可爱的小白袜。我记得低头看着我的腿，看着石头是怎么砸在上面的。有一块甚至砸出了血。
And some kid, I guess he pulled out a banana. He threw a banana. And it landed on my houndstooth vest. And I never got that stain out.
有个孩子，我猜他掏出了一根香蕉。他扔了一根香蕉。它落在了我的千鸟格背心上。我再也没能洗掉那个污渍。
Being in junior high, no matter who you are, it's hard. It just sucks. People are mean.
在初中，不管你是谁，这都很困难。简直糟糕透了。人们很刻薄。
And so I started asking her questions about this. Like, what was it like? And my mom said, think of it like Mean Girls, but they're racist. And I was like, no.
所以我开始问她关于这些的问题。比如，那是什么样的？我妈说，把它想象成《贱女孩》，但他们是种族主义者。我就说，不。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Like that's the analogy where I fully understood. I was like, oh, my god.
就像那是让我完全理解的比喻。我当时说，天哪。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
That's too mean.
那太刻薄了。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Did you make any friends?
你有交到朋友吗？
When I was in eighth grade, we sat in alphabetical order. And so the girl in front of me, her last name started with S also. So she was new to the school, too. So we were both new. And so--
我在八年级时，我们按字母顺序坐。坐在我前面的女孩，她的姓也以S开头。所以她也是学校的新生。所以我们俩都是新人。然后——
This was a white girl?
这是个白人女孩？
She was a white girl. I was the only black in the class. She became my friend. And she was real smart. And I was real smart. But I guess we were too friendly.
她是个白人女孩。我是班里唯一的黑人。她成了我的朋友。她很聪明。我也很聪明。但我猜我们太友好了一些。
There was a class for kids that were extremely smart. But I didn't think she was any smarter than I was. But they pulled her out and put her in that class. And I will always believe they did that because we were too close. You could just see their face change if another white person came into the room or down the hall. It's like, they turned their head like, who's watching me talk to this black person?
当时有一个针对极其聪明孩子的班级。但我并不认为她比我聪明。但他们把她挑出来放进了那个班。我永远相信他们这么做是因为我们关系太近了。你能看到如果另一个白人走进房间或走廊，他们的脸就会变。就像他们扭过头去心想：谁在看我跟这个黑人说话？
When I learned about the civil rights movement in school, I got a pretty truncated version of it. I remember learning about the Little Rock Nine. And I saw that famous picture of them entering Central High School surrounded by US soldiers. And then desegregation happened. And now we get to use the same bathrooms. That's pretty much all I got.
当我在学校学习民权运动时，我得到的是一个相当删减的版本。我记得学习过“小石城九人”。我看到了那张著名的他们被美国士兵包围进入中央高中的照片。然后种族隔离取消了。现在我们能用同一个洗手间了。这就是我学到的全部。
I didn't know about what those kids went through on a day-to-day basis. But my mother, on the other hand, did. The school she eventually went to was just a little over an hour away from Little Rock. And she was paying very close attention to what was going on there.
我不知道那些孩子每天经历了什么。但另一方面，我母亲知道。她最终去的学校离小石城只有一个多小时的路程。她一直在密切关注那里发生的事情。
In Little Rock, the Little Rock Nine, when they integrated Central High School, nine black kids. And they had a lady named Daisy somebody.
在小石城，“小石城九人”，当他们整合中央高中时，九个黑人孩子。他们有一个叫Daisy什么的人。
That's Daisy Bates, the head of the Arkansas chapter of the NAACP at the time.
那是Daisy Bates，当时全国有色人种协进会阿肯色州分会的负责人。
She would walk these kids to school every day. She would listen to them. And I mean, this is stuff I read in the newspaper, how she was sympathetic to what they were going through. And all day long, people were calling them the nigger. Or the teacher calling the nigger. Or the kids calling them niggers.
她每天会陪这些孩子上学。她会倾听他们。我的意思是，这些是我在报纸上读到的，她是如何同情他们所经历的一切。整天，人们都叫他们“黑鬼”。或者老师叫他们“黑鬼”。或者孩子们叫他们“黑鬼”。
In Ebony magazine, we would read this how sympathetic she was to them. And they had somebody to talk to. We didn't get that.
在《Ebony》杂志上，我们会读到她是多么同情他们。他们有人可以倾诉。我们没有。
To be clear, the Little Rock Nine were as viciously persecuted as any black students at the time. They were spat on, verbally and physically abused, attacked with fire and acid. But my mom still envied them because in her mind, those kids had access to the one thing that would have made her own situation more bearable. They had the ear of a caring adult.
需要说明的是，“小石城九人”受到的迫害和当时任何黑人学生一样恶毒。他们被唾弃、口头和身体虐待，被火和酸攻击。但我妈妈仍然羡慕他们，因为在她看来，那些孩子可以接触到能让她的处境变得更易忍受的一样东西。他们有可以倾诉的有爱心的成年人。
What was your relationship with your mom like?
你和你妈妈的关系怎么样？
She had lots of kids. She had seven kids. She always made me feel like I was the runt of the litter.
她有很多孩子。她有七个孩子。她总是让我觉得我是那一窝里最弱小的那个。
I was dark. I had really tight, kinky hair. I wasn't high-yellow like a couple of my sisters. I did not have long hair like a couple of my sisters. So I was black. I was chunky, dunky, dusty.
我皮肤很黑。我的头发又紧又卷。我不像我的几个姐妹那样肤色较浅。我的头发不像我的几个姐妹那样长。所以我很黑。我胖乎乎的，又脏又旧。
She favored the lighter kids or wanted you guys to have--
她偏爱那些肤色较浅的孩子，还是想让你们有——
She treated them differently.
她对待她们的方式不同。
What her mother was teaching her was the same thing her country was teaching her, that her blackness was less valuable.
她母亲教给她的是和这个国家教给她的一样，那就是她的黑人身份价值较低。
If she's buying cute little dresses for all of her daughters, I shouldn't be the one that didn't get the dress and have to wait till my fat sister outgrew it and then I get it. I shouldn't be the one that when it's time to comb hair, make their hair look cute. And then when she gets to me and she's tired, she just throws a few plaits on my head and they're going every which a'way. I started combing my own hair when I was like sixth grade because I knew she was not go put herself out to make me look good. So I had to figure it out myself.
如果她给所有的女儿买可爱的小裙子，我不应该是那个没裙子穿、不得不等胖姐妹穿不下后才能穿的那个人。我不应该是那个该梳头时，把她们的头发梳得很可爱，而轮到我时她累了，就随便在我头上编几根辫子，弄得乱七八糟的那个人。我在六年级时就开始自己梳头了，因为我知道她绝不会费心让我看起来漂亮。所以我必须自己想办法。
Of all the stuff we talked about, this is the part that made me the most sad. She feels the way she does about white people because white people were so terrible to her. And I get that. But there's something else going on. She's mad at her mom for putting her in that situation, forcing her to go to a place where white people could treat her that way.
在我们谈论的所有事情中，这是让我最难过的一部分。她对白人有那样的感觉，是因为白人对她太糟糕了。我理解这一点。但还有别的事情在发生。她在生她母亲的气，气她把她置于那种境地，强迫她去一个白人可以那样对待她的地方。
Where I went to school, where I live, the job I have-- all those things are a direct result of desegregation. My life would have been totally different otherwise. And listening back to the recording of our conversation, I couldn't believe how many times I asked her if she was proud of her contribution.
我去学校的地方、我住的地方、我做的工作——所有这些都是种族融合的直接结果。否则我的人生会完全不同。回听我们谈话的录音，我不敢相信我多少次问她是否为自己的贡献感到骄傲。
Do you look at that time and think about how you've helped change things in America? Do you see it as a--
你回首那段时光，有没有想过你是如何帮助改变了美国的事物？你把它看作是一个——
No. No.
不。没有。
Do you feel like you affected future generations?
你觉得你影响了后代吗？
No. It was going to happen anyway. It's just that we get tortured in the process.
没有。无论如何它都会发生。只是我们在过程中受了折磨。
So you just would have rather not have been a part of it.
所以你宁愿自己没有参与其中。
Correct. It was all very unfortunate.
正确。这完全是一个不幸。
Well-- I don't know. I mean, I'm-- it's not all very unfortunate. It's actually very fortunate, like a lot has changed. I--
嗯——我不知道。我的意思是，我——这并不是完全不幸。这实际上是非常幸运的，因为很多东西改变了。我——
Yeah, a lot has changed. But for that small group of people who went through this process, we got caught in the crossfire.
是的，很多东西改变了。但对于经历这个过程的那一小群人来说，我们成了交火的牺牲品。
So if you could go back in time, you wouldn't even do it?
所以如果能回到过去，你甚至不会去做？
No.
不。
It would be so easy for my mom to just say yes, even one time. People who weren't even in the civil rights movement claim that they were a part of the civil rights movement. I get that this was a hard period in her life. But I figured she could at least see how it benefited me.
我妈妈只要说一次是，就会变得很容易。那些甚至没有参加民权运动的人都声称自己是民权运动的一部分。我明白这是她人生中一段艰难的时期。但我以为她至少能看到这对我是如何有益的。
I went to school with all sorts of kids. And kids did give me trouble. But it wasn't the white kids.
我和各种各样的孩子一起上学。孩子们确实给我找过麻烦。但那不是白人孩子。
There was like a field day or something outside. And I was in the circle of white girls. And then I went over to the circle of black girls. And this one girl turned around, boxed me out of the circle, and was like, "why don't you go back and play with your little white friends?"
有一次外面好像有运动会什么的。我当时在白人女孩的圈子里。然后我走到黑人女孩的圈子里。结果一个女孩转过身，把我挤出圈外，说：“你为什么不回去跟你那些白人小朋友一起玩？”
And I cried instantly. I went to the curb by myself, just cried. And my white girlfriends came over. And they were like, what's wrong? And I was like, get away from me.
我立刻哭了。我自己走到路边，只是哭。我的白人女友过来问我怎么了。我说，离我远点。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
This is your fault. And then my black girlfriends came over. And they're like, what's wrong? And I was like, Star made me cry. And I explained the whole thing. And then they were like, she has no right to say that. You can hang out with whoever you want.
这是你们的错。然后我的黑人女友过来，问怎么了。我说，Star让我哭了。我解释了整个事情。然后她们说，她没权利那么说。你想跟谁玩就跟谁玩。
That was the first time I encountered a thing where someone was like, you can't hang out with a certain group of people, even if it's your own group of people. But, yeah, there was always that separation but not the way my mom had experienced.
那是第一次我遇到有人说，你不能和某一群人在一起，即使那也是你自己的群体。但是，是的，总是存在那种隔阂，但方式不像我妈经历的那样。
My mom even asked me one day. She was like, are you afraid of black people because I primarily had a lot of white friends. Which really screwed me up because my mom's black. And I was definitely afraid of her.
我妈有一天甚至问我。她说，你是不是害怕黑人，因为我主要的很多朋友都是白人。这真的让我很困惑，因为我妈是黑人。而我确实很害怕她。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
One time you asked me if I was scared of black people. Do you remember that?
有一次你问我是否害怕黑人。你记得吗？
Uh-uh.
嗯。
I don't know when it was or why. I mean, I'm assuming I was in middle school or elementary school or something. But yeah, you said-- you asked, "are you afraid of black people?" And I--
我不记得是什么时候或为什么了。我的意思是，我假设我是在初中或小学什么的。但是是的，你说——你问，“你害怕黑人吗？”而我——
What did you say?
你怎么说的？
I said, no. But I think-- I assumed that question came because I mostly had white friends. And I was like, does she think I don't want to hang around black people? Kind of gave me a little complex.
我说，没有。但我认为——我假设那个问题是因为我大部分朋友是白人。而我就在想，她是不是觉得我不想和黑人在一起？这让我产生了一些情结。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I felt a little paranoid that I had so many white friends, like it was a bad thing. Not just because of you. You weren't the only person to do that. But I wasn't expecting someone in my household to also do what the bullies at my school were doing.
我感到有点多疑，因为我有这么多白人朋友，好像这成了一件坏事。不仅仅因为你。你不是唯一一个这样做的人。但我没指望家里人也会做那些学校里欺负我的人正在做的事情。
It's not like I was-- did I say it more than once?
不是说我——我说了不止一次吗？
No, but once is really all you need to do it. I know you didn't mean to hurt me or make me feel bad, but that's what happened.
没有，但一次就足够了。我知道你并不是有意要伤害我或让我难过，但事情就是这样发生了。
Mhm.
嗯。
There's a lot of stuff that parents say that--
有很多父母说的话——
Yeah, it's--
是的，这——
--they don't realize is going to affect their kids like that.
——他们没有意识到会那样影响他们的孩子。
Tell me about it. I get-- mm.
跟我说说看。我——嗯。
Do you have an example? You don't have to get into it i you don't want to.
你觉得我问你这些问题怎么样？
No.
我很高兴你对此持开放态度，因为我和我母亲之间没有这样。我很高兴你对我感到好奇。但我母亲不让我对她感到好奇。
How do you feel about me asking you these questions?
我和我妈妈的关系从来不是最亲密的。她和我爸在我九岁时分开了。在某个时候，我开始把对他们离婚的很多愤怒集中在她身上。她对我一直非常严格。所以我们经常吵架。
I'm glad you open to it because I didn't get this with my mother. And I'm glad you're curious about me. But my mother wouldn't let me be curious about her.
最终，我去了外地上大学，紧张关系缓解了一些。但这主要是因为我们谈话少了。现在我变老了，也经历过不少治疗，我一直在试着放下那些怨恨。我试着把我母亲看作一个完整的人。
My mom and I have never had the closest relationship. She and my dad split up when I was nine. And at some point, I started to focus a lot of my anger over their divorce onto her. She was always very strict with me. So we fought a lot.
[笑声]
Eventually, I went away to college and the tension eased up a bit. But that's mostly because we talked less. Now that I've gotten older and sat through my fair share of therapy, I've been trying to let some of that resentment go. And I'm trying to think of my mother more as a whole person.
我是一个人。
[LAUGHTER]
我知道。但在很长一段时间里，我不这么认为。
I am a person.
[笑声]
I know. But for a long time, I didn't think so.
哦。
[LAUGHTER]
你觉得我们的关系怎么样？
Oh.
我不知道。我们真的没有多少时间在一起。自从你搬到纽约后，我们就没有深入交谈过了。所以我不太确定我对它感觉如何，因为我够不着你。
How do you feel about our relationship?
我不记得我们有过多少次深入的谈话。
I don't know. We don't really get to spend very much time. Since you've moved to New York, we don't have any deep conversations anymore. So I'm not sure how I feel about it because I can't get my hands on you.
嗯，青少年嘛，他们不会的。
I don't remember us having too many deep conversations.
嗯，他们可以的。
Well, teenagers, they don't.
你知道，像大多数单亲家长一样，我有很多事情要处理，要维持工作，要抚养孩子，还要处理前夫的法律纠纷。我忙不过来。而你在学校里做着所有那些事。你在拿好成绩。你有你自己的事情要忙。
Well, they can.
是的，我做到了。
You know, like most single parents, I had a lot on my table, trying to maintain a job, trying to raise kids, dealing with legal drama with my ex. My plate was full. And you're doing all this stuff at school. And you're getting your good grades. And you had your own thing going.
嗯。
Yeah, I did.
但我确实觉得我，我猜，感受到了隔阂，或者说感受到了怨恨，因为你有你自己的事，我也有我自己的事。
Mhm.
哦，那是青少年会有的感觉。
But I do feel like I like, I guess, felt a separation or felt like, I guess, resentment for you having your own thing and me having my own thing.
我不知道是不是。
Oh, that's a teenager thing.
嗯，我记得我十几岁的时候，大部分时间都在生我妈妈的气。
I don't know if it is.
但你一直在生你妈妈的气，直到她去世。你有没有发现你和你妈的关系，以及我们的关系之间有什么相似之处？
Well, I remember when I was a teenager, and I was most of the time mad at my mother.
一点也没有。
But you stayed mad at your mother for the rest of her life. Do you see any parallels between your relationship with your mom and our relationship?
即使我们仍然在大多数事情上意见不合，至少我们在交谈。那是新的。我喜欢这样。
Not at all.
我有没有告诉过你我曾和一个白人男的约会？
Even though we still don't agree on most things, at least we're talking. That's new. I like it.
没有，你没有告诉过我。
Did I ever tell you I dated a white guy?
[笑声]
No, you did not.
什么？是什么时候的事？
[LAUGHTER]
大学毕业后，我住在小石城。我当时在和那个白人男的约会。
What? When was this?
他长什么样？他高吗？
After I got out of college, I was living in Little Rock. And I was dating this white guy.
不，他不高。
What'd he look like? Was he tall?
真的？
No, he was not.
他只是——只是一个优秀的犹太男孩。
Really?
犹太人？
He was just-- just a good Jewish boy.
[笑声]
Jewish?
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
哇。你和个矮个犹太人约会过？
Yeah.
是的。
Whoa. You dated a short Jew?
[笑声]
Yes, I did.
哇。那——我完全没想到。我只是假设——因为爸爸身高一米九五，所以我只是以为你喜欢高个子男的。那挺酷。我有很多矮个子犹太朋友。
[LAUGHTER]
她告诉我他们约会了三个月，然后她因为她妈甩了他。她叔叔有一天晚上看到她和他出去。
Wow. That-- I did not expect that at all. I just assumed-- because Papa's 6'5", so I was like, I just assumed you liked tall guys. That's cool. I have a lot of short, Jewish friends.
他说，“你在和一个白人男人约会？我要打电话给你妈，告诉她你在这儿做什么。”所以那天晚上我们回家后，我就跟他断了。
She told me that they dated for three months, and then she dumped him because of her mom. Her uncle saw her out one night with him.
哇。
And he said, "you dating a white man? I'm going to call your mama and tell her what you doing up here." So when we got home that night, I was done with him.
我只是没那么喜欢他，觉得这值得跟我妈进行一场我想进行的谈话。
Wow.
我理解。决定和母亲谈论什么话题从来都不容易。
I was just not that into him to think that this was worthy of a conversation I wanted to have with my mother.
Sasheer Zamata，你可以在《周六夜现场》看到她。
I get that. It's never easy to figure out what conversations to have with your mother.
接下来，我利用自己作为广播电台主持人的平台，问了一个我想问多年的问题——来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，我们的节目继续。
Sasheer Zamata, you can see her on television on Saturday Night Live.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代班Ira Glass。我们今天的节目是关于随着年龄增长而变得更有意义的事情。我们已经到了中年，一个人开始怀疑，这到老了会有意义吗？这一切？我所做的选择、从事的工作、居住的地方、我花时间的方式，以及我没有花时间的方式。那是我想得很多的一个问题。
Coming up, I use my platform as a radio show host to ask a question I have been wanting to ask for years-- from WBEZ Chicago, when our program continues.
我办公桌里有一封信。有点言过其实，但它表达了重点。我四岁的孩子在保姆的协助下写了它。上面写着：“亲爱的妈妈，我不希望你再次离开。爱你的，Jacob。”
It's This American Life . I'm Chana Joffe-Walt sitting in for Ira Glass. Our show today is about things that make more sense when you're older. We've arrived at middle age, when a person begins to wonder, will this make sense when I'm older? Any of it? The choices I'm making, the work I'm doing, the place I live, how I'm spending my time, and how I'm not spending my time. That's one I think about a lot.
所以我做对了吗，做了正确的选择吗？20年后，当我50多岁时，我会后悔这些选择吗？我认为人们试图回答这个问题的一种经典方式是找一个正在经历50多岁生活的人去问他们。我身边就有一个，从事同样的工作。
There's a letter in my desk at work. It's a little over the top, but it gets its point across. My four-year-old wrote it with the assistance of his babysitter. It reads, "Dear mommy, I don't want you to go away again. Love, Jacob."
站在麦克风的那一侧感觉如何？
So am I doing this right, making the right choices? And I'm going to regret these choices in 20 years in my 50s? I think a sort of classic way people try to answer this question is to find someone in their 50s who's living it and ask them. I've got one right nearby, same line of work.
糟糕透了。
How does it feel to be on that side of the mic?
真的吗？
Awful.
感觉还行。
Does it really?
Ira同意在上周坐飞机前和我谈谈。所以我们在这里。第三幕：中年。我们要谈谈Ira所做的选择。Ira这样描述他的30多岁。
Feels fine.
每一刻，我不是在工作就是在睡觉。就像那是我做的两件事，而且对此毫无意见。
Ira agreed to talk to me before he got on a plane last week. So here we are. Act Three: Middle Age. And we're talking about the choices Ira's made. Ira describes his 30s this way.
我最近注意到你确实做了一些不仅仅是工作的事情。
Every moment, I was either working or asleep. Like those were the two things I did and didn't have a problem with it.
是的，那绝对是真的。
I have noticed recently that you do do some things that are not just working.
我记得你告诉我当你和某人在一起时——或者你要出去吃饭，你说了一些类似的话，是的，我最近开始尝试一种叫“朋友”的新事物。
Yes, that's definitely true.
[大笑]是的。
I remember you told me when you were hanging out with someone-- or you were going out to dinner and you said something like, yeah, I've started to try this new thing called friends recently.
真的很——很酷。
(LAUGHING) Yeah.
太棒了。
It's really-- it's cool.
是的，很有趣。
It's amazing.
是的，真的很有趣。
Yeah, it's fun.
但这已经是两年前的事了，Ira。在那之前发生了什么？
Yeah, it's really fun.
我有朋友，但不会经常见面，是我喜欢的人，但我们不会见面，你知道吗？
But that was two years ago, Ira. What happened before then?
是的。
I had friends who I wouldn't see that often, people I liked, but we wouldn't see each other, you know?
是的。我是说，事实是我现在确实安排了各种各样我五年前或十年前绝不会做的事情，比如工作日的晚上7点或8点。然后我就去做了。而且——
Yeah.
你为什么开始做那些了？
Yeah. I mean, the fact is I definitely do schedule all kinds of things now that I never would have five years ago, or 10 years ago, like during the week at night at 7 o'clock or 8 o'clock. And then I go do them. And--
为了好玩。
Why did you start doing that?
为什么？
For fun.
为了我自己的消遣。我在那方面很正常。我想见人。有我喜欢的人。我想见他们。
Why?
那是你希望更早做的一件事吗？
My own amusement. I'm normal in that way. I wanted to see people. There's people I like. I wanted to see them.
是的。
Is that a thing that you wish you had done earlier?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。我是说我希望我能为自己创造更多的空间，而不是一直工作，肯定的。但我不想得那么厉害，以至于我愿意为此采取行动。你懂我的意思吗？所以实际上，我到底有多想要？当我看到它的时候，我想要它。我认为那看起来不错。但在实践中——什么是那个东西——你一直在问自己的问题是什么？
It is?
我并不是一直都在问这些问题，但相当规律地，有一个时刻我会退后一步。我就想我不知道20年或30年后，我会不会觉得那才是我30多岁时应该做的事情，当我的孩子还小，当我的父母还健在的时候。
Yeah. Like I wish I'd created more space for myself and I wasn't working all the time, for sure. But I don't want it enough that I'd do anything about it. You know what I mean? So then, really, how much do I want it? I want it when I see it. I think that seems good. But then in practice-- what's the thing-- what are the questions that you're asking yourself that are leading to this?
是的。
I'm not asking these questions all the time, but fairly regularly there is a moment where I step back. And I'm like I don't know if in 20 years or 30 years I'm going to be like that's what I should have been doing when I was in my 30s, when my kids were little, when my parents were still alive.
是的，我猜那不仅仅是时刻。我经常有这种想法。经常。那些似乎不是你的问题。看起来——我不知道。你30多岁时我不认识你。但现在，看起来你非常单一导向。而且你没有其他所有问题的焦虑。
Yeah.
我没有。
Yeah, I guess it's not just moments. I have it a lot. I have it a lot. Those don't seem to be questions for you. It seems like-- I don't know. I didn't know you when you were in your 30s. But right now, it seems like you are very singularly directed. And you don't have the anxiety of all the other questions.
是的。
I don't.
Yeah.
你曾经有过吗？
我是说，你的情况不同，因为你有孩子，你知道吗？
Did you ever have that?
是的。
I mean, you're in a different situation because you have kids, you know?
但你在想，我曾被疑虑折磨吗？我没有。你一直在想这个问题。而我从来不去想这个问题。而且我从来没有真正想过。
Yeah.
是的。我无法想象决定我唯一想做的事就是工作和睡觉。我完全无法想象。不，我会错过很多事情的。
But you're wondering, was I plagued by doubt? And I wasn't. You think about this all the time. And I never think about this. And I never really did think about this.
你看，当你这么说的时候，这是——这让我有了种感觉，比如，哦，等等。我比我想象中在这方面更像个怪人，我通常根本不这么想自己。但我依然为我做出的选择感到庆幸。
Yeah. I can't imagine deciding the only thing I want to do is work and sleep. I totally can't imagine that. No, I would miss things.
我感觉我从这一切中得到的是，你和我有很多共同点。但我们是完全不同的人类。
See, when you say this, this is-- this gives me this feeling of like, oh, wait. I'm more of a weirdo than I thought in this way which I don't usually think of myself at all. But I still am glad for the choice I made.
而这让我实际上成了最不该问咨询建议的人。我跟你太不同了，没法给你任何建议。我是说，你和我不一样的地方就是对空闲时间的渴望。
I feel like what I am getting from all of this is that you and I have many things in common. And we are extremely different human beings.
而你没有。你没有。
And that makes me actually the very worst person to ask this advice from. I'm too different from you to give you any advice. I mean, the thing that's different for you is a desire for free time.
[大笑]不。不，我没有。
Which you don't have. You didn't have.
Ira Glass是本节目的主持人，只是本周不是。
(LAUGHING) No. No, I didn't.
第四幕：老年。所以我们从小时候开始。有些事情你是不知道的。你是无法理解的。然后你长大了，你就懂了。
Ira Glass is the host of this show, just not this week.
我们坠入爱河。这就是爱。或者有人告诉你“妓女”是什么意思。我对此记忆犹新。事物最终是有意义的。
Act Four: Old Age. So we begin when you're little. And there are things you do not know. You can't understand. And then you grow up, and you get it.
这最后一个故事，是关于那之后会发生什么，很久很久之后。它是关于一个叫Carl Duzen的人。Carl在一年半前，79岁时被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病。所以在几十年的成年生活后，一个40岁的医生突然问他一些问题，比如，你能告诉我总统是谁吗？或者，你记得你的名字吗？这突然变得合情合理。
We fall in love. This is love. Or someone tells you what "hooker" means. I remember that vividly. Stuff eventually makes sense.
当Carl去看医生时，他总是和妻子Susan一起。他总是讨厌去。而且他总是记得自己的名字。
This last story, it's about what happens after that, long after that. It's about a man named Carl Duzen. Carl was diagnosed with Alzheimer's a year and a half ago at age 79. So after decades of adulthood, it is suddenly appropriate for a 40-year-old doctor to ask him questions like, can you tell me who the president is? Or, do you remember your name?
所以，你应该总是问的一个问题，基本上，在某个时间画一个时钟。
When Carl goes to the doctor, he always goes with his wife Susan. He always hates going. And he always knows his name.
它是用文字写着“画一个时钟”吗？
So one of the questions that you should always ask, make a picture, basically, of a clock at such and such a time.
是的，圆形的表盘。
It says in words "draw a clock"?
明白了。
Yes, the round face.
你能画一个时间为11点20分的模拟时钟吗？
I see.
Carl的妻子Susan告诉我，最近有一天，她开车送Carl去预约。Carl进去了。Carl告诉我他在那儿等，手里拿着铅笔，测试员在他旁边等着，问他：“画一个时钟。”
Could you draw an analog clock with the time 11:20?
所以我拿了一张纸。不管我怎么——我只是——我不能——我做不到。
Susan, Carl's wife, tells me one day recently, she drove Carl to his appointment. Carl went in. And Carl tells me he waited there, pencil in hand, the tester waiting next to him, asking him, "draw a clock."
Carl试了一次又一次。他抬头看着测试员，低头看着纸。测试员，他的铅笔。
So I got a piece of paper. No matter what I-- I just-- I couldn't-- I couldn't do it.
所以，看着那个，是的，我做不到。
Carl tried again. He looked up at the tester, back down toward his page. Tester, his pencil.
他做不到。Carl拥有物理学研究生学位。他研究过运动、电磁学。他一生中大部分时间都深陷于对空间、时间、数字的研究。他教了多年的物理和数学。所以这个特定的失败让他感到不安。
So, look at that and yeah, I can't do it.
为什么这么难？为什么这么难？有时钟。为什么这这么难？
He can't do it. Carl got a graduate degree in physics. He studied motion, electromagnetism. He spent a lot of his life deep in the study of space and time of numbers. He taught physics and mathematics for years. So this particular failing was unnerving.
当Carl说话时，他的妻子Susan一动不动，听着，挂念着每一个细节以免错过任何东西，并在需要时插话。她比Carl高出整整一个头。他们最喜欢的笑话是，Susan说，我差点忽略了他。然后他跳到空中让她能看到他的脸。
Why is this so difficult? Why is that so hard? It's clocks. Why is that so hard?
当Carl最近说的话在现实中没什么根据时，Susan会恭敬地扬起两道质疑的眉毛，随他去吧。当他描述时钟的困难时，Susan向Carl保证他并不孤单。时钟的事情出现在她为痴呆症患者配偶举办的互助小组中。
When Carl talks, his wife Susan is completely still, listening, hanging on the details so she doesn't miss anything, jumping in with words when they're needed. She's a full head taller than Carl. Their favorite joke, as Susan says, I almost overlooked him. And then he jumps in the air so she can see his face.
在互助小组里，人们会谈论，哦，我丈夫下周和医生有个预约。所以他一直在忙着练习画时钟。哦，是的，那个时钟。哦，是的，我丈夫从来没画对过。
When Carl says things lately that don't have much basis in reality, Susan respectfully raises two questioning eyebrows, leaves it at that. As he's describing the trouble of the clock, Susan assures Carl he's not alone. The clock thing comes up in her support group for spouses of people with dementia.
嗯，因为它太普遍了。原来如此。
In the support group, people would talk about how, oh, my husband has an appointment next week with the doctor. So he's been busy practicing the clock. Oh, yeah, the clock. Oh, my husband never gets it.
[交叉对话]
Well, because it's so universal. There it is.
这就是时间。而现在突然之间，你无法搞定它了。哎。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
所以，我只是说，好吧。所以我做的是拿了一张纸。我只是坐下来。它在哪儿？让我们——
It's the time. And now suddenly, you can't manage it. Ack.
你要我跟着你吗？
And so, I just said, OK. So what I did is got a piece of paper. I just sat down. Where is it? Let's--
不，我会带上的。我会把它带回来。
Do you want me to follow you?
Carl开始四处寻找东西。去了厨房。他好像迷路了。然后上楼了。最终，他拿着一个木箱下来了。里面塞满了绘图工具。
No, I'll bring it. I'll bring it back.
那儿有什么？
Carl starts looking around for something. Goes in the kitchen. He seems to be lost. And then goes upstairs. Eventually, he comes down with a wooden box. Inside, it's felted with drafting tools.
所以，我拿了一张纸。我拿出了我用来做这种工作的工具。
What do you have there?
那就像个圆规吗？看起来像我在小学数学里用的那种圆规。
So, I got a piece of paper. I got out the tool that I have for doing this kind of work.
是的。是的。所以我心想，好吧，我打算——我和它坐在一起大约一个小时。
So that's like a compass? It looks like the sort of compass I used in math in elementary school.
需要说明的是，不一定是画时钟，而是搞清楚为什么他画不出时钟。
Yeah. Yeah. So I thought, OK, I'm going to-- I sat down with it for just about an hour.
我终于意识到问题是三个类型的叠加——
To be clear, not necessarily to draw a clock, but to figure out why he couldn't draw a clock.
类型。
And I finally realized that the problem is superposition of three--
——类型。
Types.
Carl画了一个非常精确的圆，把它分成了十二等份，并在页面的角落里用微小的字体潦草地写下了“三个类型的叠加”。他解释说，在Susan的帮助下，这里有三层信息。有从1到12表示的小时，尽管一天有24小时。
--types.
但接着，有第二层，即分钟。1不再代表1，而是5分钟。2代表10。
Carl has drawn a very precise circle, split it into twelfths, and scrawled the words "superposition of three types" in tiny letters in the corner of the page. He explains, with Susan's help, there are three layers of information here. There's the hours that are represented from 1 through 12, even though there are 24 hours in a day.
但Carl补充说，在那层之后是秒针，现在测量1到60秒。
But then, there's the second layer, which is the minutes. And a 1 represents not a 1 anymore, but 5 minutes. And a 2 represents 10.
三个类型的叠加。
But Carl adds, after that layer is the second hand, which is now measuring 1 through 60 seconds.
类型，因为你有三个不同的高度，你必须把它们放在一起才能组成信息。
Superposition of three types.
Carl坐着用他的工具和纸，带着他作为物理学家的愿望，在他面前分解问题。他拆解了时钟的每一个元素，直到它对他来说有了意义，三个层面，眼睛先看向较大的分针，你的大脑必须覆盖它，以便专注于较小的时针，尽管它更小且不是你看到的第一件事，但它实际上更重要。
Types because you have three different elevations that you have to get together to make the information.
然后你应该移动到较长的分针。但别被骗了，因为秒针也更长但更细。在这一切结束时，我只想说，天哪，时钟？我不敢相信这是我们用来计时的系统。太疯狂了。任何人都能瞥一眼自己的手腕就获取信息真是个奇迹，这可是Carl非常努力做的事情。
Carl sat with his tools and his paper and his physicist's desire to decompose the problem before him. And he took apart each element of the clock until it made sense to him, the three layers, the fact that the eye goes to the larger minute hand first and your brain has to override that to focus on the smaller hour hand, which is actually more important even though it's smaller and not the first thing you see.
所以，大脑——大脑在里面拼命尝试，当然，试图在同一时间抓住所有这些东西来做出反应。这真的太难了。然后当我做这个时，我心想，哦，这就是为什么它这么难。
And then you're supposed to move to the longer minute hand. But don't be tricked because the second hand is also longer but it's skinnier. And by the end of all this, I just feel like, what the hell, clock? I can't believe this is the system we have for telling time. It's insane. It's a miracle anyone can ever just glance at their wrist and capture information, something Carl works very hard at.
你的大脑无法帮你画时钟，但你用了你的大脑来找出为什么你的大脑无法帮你画时钟。
So and the brain-- the brain is in there trying desperately, of course, to get hold all of these things at the same time to respond to. And it's just dead hard. And then when I did this I figured, oh, that's why it's so hard.
是的，情况确实如此。我感觉我找回了一些我失去的东西。不是说我能轻易做到，而是我至少理解了为什么我会有困难。
Your brain can't help you draw a clock, but you used your brain to figure out why your brain can't help you draw a clock.
而这感觉像——
Yeah, that's kind of the way it is. I felt like that I got something back that I had lost. But not that I could do it easily for a while, but that I at least understood why I have was having trouble.
那有——它有意义。而且它有结构。
And that felt like--
而不是仅仅感觉这是一个我突然做不到的随机事件。
And that had-- it had meaning. And it had the structure.
是的。
Instead of just feeling like this is a random thing that I now suddenly can't do.
哈。
Yeah.
而且它不简单。它是困难的。所以我感觉对自己好多了。变得活泼了。更活泼了。
Huh.
[笑声]
And it isn't easy. It is difficult. And so I felt better about myself. Got perky. More perky.
痴呆症的诊断是告诉你，随着年龄增长，你不再理解事物了。这是你一生中第一次，知识的年代顺序向前发展将开始逆转。但Carl正在理解他从未知道的事物。在许多痴呆症患者身上也是如此。
[LAUGHTER]
通过遇见Carl和其他人，我采访过一位忘记如何煮咖啡的女士。然后她拆解了其中的步骤，以便能再次做到。一个重新学会使用手机的男士。这是Carl也做过的事情。
A dementia diagnosis is being told you are now no longer going to understand things as you get older. For the first time in your life, the chronological forward march of knowledge will begin to reverse itself. But Carl is understanding things he never knew before. And this is the case with lots of people with dementia.
Carl对时钟的了解远超过我们大多数人，只是因为他忘记了如何画它。你会在需要知道时学到你需要知道的东西。Carl现在骄傲地告诉我，他理解了三种类型的叠加，他可以再次用它来读表。Susan怀疑地挑起眉毛看着他，但什么也没说。
Through meeting Carl and other people, I talked to a woman who forgot how to make coffee. And then she broke down the steps involved so she could do it again. A guy who re-learned to use his cell phone. That's something Carl has also done.
从我被告知患有阿尔茨海默病到现在，那些我放下的东西，因为我曾经教过的物理学这类东西，我甚至不能告诉你那是什么。那消失了。有一段时间，我无法使用电脑，记得如何使用它。而现在我可以用时钟——
Carl knows way more about a clock than most of us only because he forgot how to draw one. You learn what you need to know when you need to know it. Carl tells me proudly now that he understands the superposition of three types, he can use that to read a watch again. Susan raises her eyebrows skeptically at this, but says nothing.
手表。
From the time that I was told that I had Alzheimer's to now, the things that I had let go of because kinds of things in physics that I used to teach I can't even tell you what it is. That's gone. For a while, I couldn't use my computer, remember how to use it. And now I can go with a clock--
Watch.
你能看时间吗？
在这个上，真的很难。但它在这儿。
Can you tell the time?
你要看我的吗？
On this one, it's really tough. But here it is.
[听不清]好的，这就是它——
You want to look at mine?
在这儿，Carl，看我的。
[INAUDIBLE] OK, here's where it--
好的。
Here, Carl, look at mine.
Carl戴着手表，但很小。他似乎不知道怎么处理它被袖子的一部分盖住的事实。Susan拿出了她的金表，表盘大得多。
OK.
好的。所以你在寻找信息。你会选择这个，因为这是最重要的。它看起来像。它是最大的一个。
Carl's wearing a watch, but it's small. And he doesn't seem to know how to deal with the fact that it's covered by part of his sleeve. Susan pulls out her gold watch, which has a much larger face.
你指着秒针。
OK. So you're looking around for information. You would go for this because that's the most important thing. It looks like it. It's the biggest one.
是的。然后这边有个很小很小的。
You're pointing to the second hand.
短而粗的那一个。
Yes. And then there's this little bitty one over here.
短而粗的那一个。它是最小的东西。就是那小片，你看到了吗？那就是小时的那个。那就是小时一小时一小时地做这件事的那个。
The short stubby one.
你每次看手表都必须想通每一个步骤吗？
The short stubby one. It's the smallest little thing. It's that little piece, you see? And that's the hour one. That's the one, hour by hour, that does the whole thing.
好的，所以这是——嗯，这里有那个小片。现在我们处于——让我们看看——12，1——
You have to think through each of those steps every time you look at a watch?
Carl停止了说话，正盯着手表看。Susan看起来非常紧张。我们都在前倾。后来，我意识到我是在这时停止呼吸的。Carl在那个时针上花了一段时间，然后开始绕着表的表面低声数着五。
OK, so this is-- well, here we are with the little piece. And now we are at-- let's see-- 12, 1--
5，10，15，20，25，30，35，40。1点40？是的。我就是这么做的。
Carl stops talking and is staring intensely at the watch. Susan looks very nervous. We are all leaning in. Later, I will realize that here is where I stopped breathing. Carl spends a while on that hour hand and then starts counting by fives in a whisper around the face of the watch.
是的，太棒了。
5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40. 1:40? Yeah. That's how I do it.
那是什么感觉？
Yeah, that's fantastic.
[拍手]
What did that feel like?
[笑声]
[CLAPPING]
很好。很好。
[LAUGHTER]
你担心——所以现在你有这种分析水平，通过思考看时钟涉及什么来帮助了解如何看时钟，你担心你会忘记它吗？
It's good. It's good.
当然。这就是为什么我必须这么做。没有回头路。
Do you worry-- so now you have this level of analysis that helps how know how to read a clock by thinking about what is involved in reading a clock, do you worry that you're going to forget this?
没有回头路回到你曾经能够不假思索地画出时钟的日子。
Sure. That's why I have to do this. There's no path back.
没有回头路。
There's no path back to a day when you used to be able to draw a clock using-- without having to think about it.
有很多事情在年长时，也就是成年时会变得更有意义。然后有些事情在真正变老时会变得有意义，当你开始理解失去事物时。这就是我肯定的我们大多数人在自己经历之前无法完全领悟的，去知道——去真正知道——没有回头路。
There's no path back.
我们的节目今天由Zoe Chace制作，Sean Cole、Neil Drumming、Stephanie Foo、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike协助。我们的资深制作人是Brian Reed。我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。Julie Snyder是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。制作协助来自[听不清] Smith。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的业务运营经理。Elna Baker为我们的节目搜寻故事。Kimberly Henderson是我们的办公室协调员。Christopher Swetala提供研究协助。Damian Graef和Rob Geddis提供音乐协助。
There are a lot of things that make sense when you're older, as in a grown-up. And then there are things that make sense when you're actually getting old, when you start to make sense of losing things. That is what I'm sure most of us cannot fully grasp until we get there ourselves, to know-- to really know-- there is no path back.
[鸣谢]
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace with Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from [INAUDIBLE] Smith. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送到公共广播电台。对我老板Ira Glass，他大方地让我本周代班主持人——
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
呵，多谢款待啊。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. And to my boss, Ira Glass, who graciously let me sit in as host this week--
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira下周会回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Like, thanks for the hospitality.
那个，谢谢你的款待。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。